and it's time again to play one of my
favorite games compare and contrast
today's example how to handle a migrant
crisis now in the u.s. tearing screaming
children from the arms of their sobbing
parents as they seek to enter at the
Mexican border possibly illegally was
until recently deemed appropriate the
children were then kept in cages usually
without books or toys now in Germany we
have Angela Merkel's creaking coalition
government possibly about to collapse
due to pressures created by her
open-door policy for migrants meanwhile
on world refugee day this week it was
revealed more than 34,000 have died
trying to get to Europe in the last 25
years migration is one of the biggest
issues facing the world neither mr.
Trump with his brutal attempts at
deterrence or Frau Merkel who's waiting
welcome has seen thousands perish has
the answer but we do need one and we
need it fast if you say we need an
answer I don't think there is an answer
especially in Europe you know the the
the melting pot I don't think can be
salvaged there I don't think anyone
could look at what's happening in
Germany or in Italy or in lots of the
other countries across there you even
say that it's actually working the EM
you know the populace are on the march
in countries like the Czech Republic and
Italy Poland and is everything you meant
mentioned Trump and it's hideous what
he's what he's doing you don't want to
be part of a country that does that but
it's interesting the Trump threatened to
erect a war to keep Mexicans out of the
US but what we never talk about here is
the fact that in Europe they've erected
wolves all over Europe they've Hungary
of erected walls to keep out migrants
Austria has Bulgaria has you know the
the the mood is changing and it's
changing because of mrs merkel's
immigration policy to let a million-plus
immigrants in it's cause chaos it's
changed cultures overnights in some
countries you know there are 11 populist
parties now across the EU and all of
them have more than 20% support you guys
all have heard of a historian called
Niall Ferguson he said this week Italy's
populace of the future Merkel is the
past and what mrs. Merkel has done with
this open-door policy she has
she's fractured Europe it's ironic she's
actually splitting you let's bring Greg
enough I just want to read this Frances
finance minister effectively their
Chancellor Bruno Lamia
says Europe is in a process of
disintegration we see states that a
turning inward trying to find national
solutions to problems that require
European solutions that's about as grim
as it gets isn't it great I think but is
there a solution I mean we're making the
assumption but because we have a
political problem there is always a
political solution I'm not too sure when
you get movements of population on the
scale we've seen in recent years
sixty-eight million people I move last
year most of if you actually look at the
the figures of coming into EU you know
Greece twenty five thousand it's only
seventy eight thousand Germany five
hundred and twenty four thousand France
110,000 and the UK twenty eight thousand
Karen are what I want to bring you in
just briefly Angela Merkel who you
mentioned and Emmanuel macron had a
meeting this week and they talked about
possibly building detention centers in
Libya or in Niger or places like that I
want to hear your point but your
reaction to that you see that the
problem was if you look at the figures
in 2015 there were 1.3 million asylum
applicants in the EU and this is very
much linked to breaks it because in 2016
the year after that if you polled people
then number one issue sixty percent of
them said their fear of immigration was
number one issue sixty percent
now that's dropped to as low as thirty
percent because even the numbers have
now dropped the asylum seekers now have
come down to half building these camps
note so what I want to just make this
point don't that there's this perception
and fear of migration but which was at
its peak with if you remember Nigel
Farage and those pictures of queues of
migrants coming in that really really
scared the British public before and an
immigration became a number-one issue it
is not any longer the fear of
immigration is nowhere near as far as it
was noticed the statistics show there
graphs that showed what Angela Merkel
did by the way she now
realizes a mistake we've got a
controlled immigration okay what we have
lost control of is the illegal
immigration you know in the UK alone the
former head of the borders agency after
he retired he said I don't know how many
illegal in was there maybe up to 1
million here that one David Cameron when
we were all talking about taking in
silent seekers from from Syria wherever
and remember David Cameron said the
policy was build camps over then
everyone Popo that inhuman they said no
you're being a good idea so I think it's
really interesting to look at what's
happened to Trump in the u.s. debate
because I think it shows how even
somebody who is so hardline about
closing down borders has to eventually
make some concessions to basic humanity
so unfortunately it falls to me to play
this which I find really hard to watch
segment from a really excellent report
from Greg Milan on Sky News just have a
look at this and this is what we know
now has been going on in the US
[Music]
they are the cries of young children
reportedly after they were taken from
their parents inside a u.s. Detention
Center last week campaigners who
obtained this recording say it reveals
the truth of the forced separation of
thousands of migrant families this is
what it looks like inside the largest of
those detention centers hundreds of
children held in cages with just tin
foil blankets for comfort the innocence
caught in the middle of Donald Trump's
zero tolerance on illegal border
crossings is and I don't use the word
lightly genuinely heartbreaking and so
much though that even the Republican
rights have been piling freshened right
and this is what he's now says as you as
I'm sure you've heard that he's had to
retract from his position today I signed
an executive order we're going to keep
families together but the border is
going to be just as tough as it's been
I mentioned that and I just finally the
last thing I'll show you which is Pape
I'm very proud of the Guardian which
used World Refugee day to publish a list
of the 34,000 361 documented I'm sure
there are many and it says not just the
name in the country of origin but how
they died and there is just some of
these I just say that to say sticking
your head in the sand is a lot of
solutions how is that worse those kid is
screaming in cages than kid is drowning
it's Marcus policy no I'm the problem
with this is no one politician can solve
this man shutting your border this is a
problem that people leaving and they are
leaving for reason and build on this
because there is a difference between
economic migrants and genuine refugees
in countries like Turkey have over 2
million Jordan millions of refugees
genuine refugees were fleeing conflict
and terror on the other hand what about
the humanitarian aspect where people
come in these boats and on sea and
there's a report from the sky news
present a mark stone out at sea with the
the ship the Aquarius we should see what
he read this is the reality you can see
the Aquarius just over there probably a
couple hundred meters away from from
where we are now as surrounding it our
Spanish Coast Guard vessels who for
understand understandable reasons are
keeping us back but we're getting a
close glimpse there of a vessel which
really has summed up the mess that
Europe is in over migration very neatly
over the course of the past week on
border 106 people who are not in a good
state they are at the end of a very very
long journey which has taken them from
their countries in Central Africa across
the Sahara Desert with the help of
traffickers into lawless Libya and then
on to those dinghies into the
Mediterranean that we've seen so many
times before this is where we have a
responsibility humanitarian response to
rescue these people but from sea and
then you know they've been accepted by
Spain but I mean what was really
worrying about the Trump thing I mean if
you've heard but mean that they think
some of these kids will never be find
their parents again they don't know but
they just say
the mob just sent him off somewhere he's
terrified but remember the I mean we
think this is a European problem
actually it's not really if you look at
the number of refugees around the world
you know Turkey Pakistan Lebanon Iran
Uganda Ethiopia Jordan at the top seven
so the idea that this is just a this is
just a European problem is not the case
Germany the real issue is that there are
four combination of reasons I suspect
partly about communications partly about
globalization as people are getting up
and moving in large numbers to try to
get a better life your nation yes we
don't know what the predicted numbers
for the people coming from sub-sahara
sub-saharan countries it's thirteen
point six million by 2050 that's an
that's a lot of people and all of them
are heading towards your on the other
hand this is where one we're an island
secondly we're not part of Schengen and
so this is a big benefit to us that we
were not part of Schengen on the other
hand we have responsibilities as well
and you know who was mrs. Thatcher who
actually stopped yesterday she said she
said remember this will affect people's
livelihoods in this country and well she
she mentioned crime as well I mean how
wise are miss Thatcher managed to manage
to get me